madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 17 juillet le
coup d'éclat de lance armstrong
l'américain impose son rythme au tour de
france il remporte l'étape à l'alpe
d'huez s'impose devant jan ullrich
mais c'est françois simon comme prévu
qui prend le maillot jaune il sera tout
à l'heure en direct avec nous dans ce
journal
la cohabitation deuxième le conseil des
ministres de demain s'annonce glaciale
après les amabilités changé ces derniers
jours pour répondre à la déferlante de
jacques chirac sur l'insécurité
lionel jospin augmente les crédits de
l'intérieur et de la justice
la veillée d'armes à gênes en italie
pour le sommet du g8 de ce week-end les
militants anti mondialisation sont déjà
là quand ils ne sont pas bloquées aux
frontières
le concorde et ses essais grandeur
nature au dessus de l'océan à vitesse
supersonique pour une reprise du service
espérée en septembre et puis les
francofolies dans la tourmente du
mauvais temps avec une découverte quand
même pascal parisot
on le surnomme le nouveau gainsbourg
nous allons d'ailleurs commencé ce
journal par le mauvais temps météo
france appelle les habitants et les
touristes de toute la façade ouest de la
france à la plus grande prudence on
annonce des vents violents inhabituelles
en cette saison françois privat et alain
darrigrand sont du côté de la rochelle
brumes de sable sur la plage une mer
formée en baie de la rochelle
durant toute la journée le vent a
soufflé le plus souvent en rafales
dépassant même les 90 km heure sur l'île
d'oléron
là c'est exceptionnel effectivement
c'est fort pascal mais tout l'hiver on a
ce genre de météo on sait faire non
c'est touristes inconscients qui via qui
va se mettre à l'eau lui à danger mais
sinon les gens du coin on est
parfaitement messieurs les ingénieurs de
météo france ne parle pas de tempête
mais d'un fort coup de vent
phénomène plutôt rare à pareille époque
de l'année ce sont des vents qu'on a
fréquemment durant l'automne et l'hiver
mais il faut dire que pour un mois de
juillet sa garde un caractère quand même
exceptionnel aussi bien par la durée du
coup de vent qu'on a et qu'on va voir
que par la force qu'on a atteint donc on
va atteindre et tout au bord de l'eau il
avait choisi de planter leurs tentes
l'afm avait là soit pas dormir avec le
vent aussi en début de soirée les
derniers plaisanciers encore sur l'eau
rentre au port quant au spectacle des
francofolies festival de chanson
française qui devait ce soir à la
rochelle accueillir plus de 6000
personnes
il est tout simplement annulé c'est pas
une décision
timide qui m'aurait parce qu'il ya eu
des incidents
dernièrement au dessus de devant à se
fendre km et reprend constants on doit
faire évacuer le lieu pour les
prochaines 24 heures
météo france maintient son avis de coup
de vent sur l'ensemble de la côte
atlantique et depuis le début du mois
les intempéries se succèdent à un rythme
désolant pour l'instant rien de
dramatique pour les cultures revanche
les touristes ne sont pas à la fête
comme l'ont constaté
nabila taboury et jean-françois chevet à
trouville même si la technique n'est pas
vraiment au point
le principal lorsqu'il pleut c'est de se
trouver une occupation averses vent et
températures dignes d'un week-end de la
toussaint le mauvais temps dure depuis
une semaine et pour les touristes venus
découvrir les charmes de la côte
normande et son climat tempéré
c'est plutôt de certains c'est le voyage
uniquement pour la journée et pour eux
seuls valent est forcément pas le détour
françois 6 aura ainsi la journée serait
comme ça je serais resté dans mon lit
travaux liés à 11h10 heure chacun mais
franchement c'est pas bien dans la plus
en plus la place s'est passé pour la
pluie c'est le soleil oubliez donc les
bains de mer la bronzette et les
châteaux de sable les cirés les gros
pulls ont remplacé les maillots de bain
et malgré tout certains touristes
restent philosophes
on était un peu découragé tout à l'heure
mais maintenant ça va on se repose au
moins pour trouville juillet août c'est
la haute saison touristique
la station balnéaire multiplie sa
population par dix avec le mauvais temps
il n'y a pas que la plage qui est
déserté les restaurateurs aussi ont du
mal à faire leur chiffre d'affaires
certains établissements ont perdu
jusqu'à 10% de leur clientèle il fait
beau barailla clvd vous refusez cents
clients
là on ne refuse personne en quinze jours
il est tombé plus de pluie que durant un
mois de juillet normal et les prévisions
pour les prochains jours ne sont guère
optimistes
pour autant la situation n'est pas
encore catastrophique
on est loin de battre les records de
pluie de l'an dernier lightroom il sait
bien dans le calvados
contrairement à ce qu'on est écrit ça
dépend en seine maritime ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'ils fassent meilleur en
seine maritime le tour de france on
savait que l'étape de l'alpe d'huez sera
une nouvelle fois décisive et l'a été
lance armstrong a joué sa partition dans
son coin avant d'imposer son tempo à jan
ullrich natel de rinxent et alain
poirier enalean bigard aucun doute
lance armstrong est toujours le meilleur
cet après midi dès les premiers virages
de l'alpe d'huez
l'américain s'est joué de tous ses
rivaux avec une facilité déconcertante
un dernier regard à hollerich en guise
d'au revoir
l'allemand dont on attendait temps n'a
pas la force de suivre armstrong
il faut dire que malgré les deux cols
hors catégorie passé aujourd'hui
l'américain scalado sprit la plus
célèbre ascension du tour une des plus
difficiles aussi derrière lui oric bello
qui est morose semble avancer au ralenti
rapidement armstrong revient sur l'oru
en tête de l'étape depuis près de deux
cents kilomètres le français avait six
minutes d'avancé sur armstrong au pied
de l'alpe d'huez
l'américain le dépasse à 5 kilomètres du
sommet s'est passé autre europe
voici les rares signes de souffrance
montré par amstrong cet après midi
l'américain passe la ligne de l'alpe
d'huez seul et au sprint avec deux
minutes avant sur ullrich
je savais même si je gagne le tour de
france il fallait pour l'étude que nous
remportions au moins une victoire
d'étape
derrière armstrong françois simon s'est
accroché le français a parfaitement su
gérer son avance au classement général
10 minutes de retard seulement sur
l'américain à l'arrivée c'est une bonne
performance
françois simon passe la ligne épuisé
mais maillot jaune il réalise le rêve de
sa vie de coureur
ce soir simon possède 20 minutes
d'avancé sur armstrong au général
de quoi voir la vie en jaune encore
quelques jours alors avec nous françois
simon qui a donc endossé le maillot
jaune on vient de le voir c'était prévu
puisque grâce à la folle échappée
d'avant-hier vous aviez je crois une
avance confortable sur les leaders près
d'une demi heure
enfin j'imagine que ça fait quand même
très plaisir non oui tout à fait ça
c'est sûr que des échappées comme comme
on a vu avant-hier c'est ça arrive
jamais
bon ben j'ai j'ai eu des chances un peu
de prendre cette bonne échappée est bon
maintenant c'est à moi de j'ai réussi à
prendre le maillot jaune aujourd'hui et
puis essayer de gérer un peu cette
avance qui me reste encore
alors pourquoi pour essayer de le
maintenir encore de trois jours alors il
ya 18 ans justement c'est votre frère
qui arrivent et en en jaune à l'alpe
d'huez et puis et ben il perdait le
maillot alors c'est un peu une revanche
de la famille non oui nous revanche si
on veut c'est sûr que parce qu'elle
m'avait appelé ce matin justement est
moins touché deux mots il m'a dit je les
perdais sur l'étape de l'alpe d'huez je
lui ai laissé là maintenant à toi de le
récupérer alors vous dites vous allez
garder ce maillot de trois jours
j'allais tout faire l'impossible pour le
garder vous espère effectivement
refranchir quelques cols avec le maillot
sur le dos ben oui bon déjà il ya un
contre la montre demain donc
c'est sûr que je vais me donner à 100%
même plutôt 110 ou 120
et puis en espérant bien sûr le gard dès
demain sort ensuite je le savourerai
pour la journée de repos et puis va
prendre car offrent les étapes des
pyrénées
en tout cas merci à françois simon
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions chez vous êtes un peu fatigué
et puis vous donne cette information sur
le dopage puisque le justement du
tribunal de reims sur la sphère de tvm
est tombé à propos du tour de france 98
un jugement en forme de dernier
avertissement contre le dopage puisque
les trois dirigeants de l'équipe
néerlandaise ne sont condamnés à de la
prison avec sursis et à des amendes
en plein débat sur la sécurité c'est un
médiateur social un emploi jeune qui est
tué d'une balle dans le dos près de lens
il avait voulu s'interposer dans une
rixe entre des jeunes lillois et son
frère cadet trois personnes ont été
placées en garde à vue sur place
harnes loïc de la mornais et marie
pierre cassignard
c'est la marche silencieuse de toute une
ville après l'assassinât d'un de ses
enfants
mustapha une ville oui mais une petite
ville calme pas une caricature de cités
chaudes et c'est bien cela qui choque
d'habitude l'insécurité ici c'est au
pire quelques incivilités pas la mort
par balle d'un médiateur de 24 ans a
connu aujourd'hui les gens cette marche
show square cette marche silencieuse
pour exprimer ensemble des sentiments
très forts de volonté de sécurité de
volonté de préserver notre vie
collective nos images avaient la santé
nos enfants dimanche dernier vers 15
heures quatre voitures arrivent d'une
banlieue de lille
à leur bord 16 personnes dont certaines
armées de source proche de l'enquêté ces
individus cherchaient une adresse sans
doute une affaire de règlement de compte
ne trouveront pas leur cible
il interroge un jeune gardien de 19 ans
la discussion s'envenime sur cette place
passant par là où cela fasse un tertre
rouge d'autant plus que le jeune prise à
partie et son frère une bagarre éclate
les deux frères s'enfuit dans cette rue
et c'est ici que mustapha s'écroule
abattu d'une balle dans le dos là on
n'arrive pas à imaginer même moment
encore je n'imagine pas encore qu'il
soit décédé quoique on les colle et
abattu lâchement qu'une bande d'une
grande ville extérieurs viennent ici
chercher les des problèmes une petite
ville de 7000 habitants
ancien éducateur profondément attaché au
dialogue mustapha n'était pas devenu
médiateur par hasard réunit dans le
local où il travaillait ses collègues le
décrivent comme un jeune qui avait la
vocation goethe afin de juger jamais une
personne avant de la connaître
c'est un mec bien que c'est un exemple
c'est un exemple pour les gens ses
collègues refusent de tout généralisée
ne veulent pas croire que l'insécurité
des banlieues va gangréné nos campagnes
quant à la roquette elle suit son cours
plusieurs personnes ont été interpellées
à lille dès dimanche soir le recours à
des médiateurs ou à des grands frères
est une pratique très répandue à roubaix
au départ il s'agissait de compenser un
manque de policiers estimé à 110 par la
municipalité
aujourd'hui 'l'annonce des fameuses
lettres plafonds du gouvernement et de
la création de 3000 emplois
supplémentaires dans la police est
particulièrement bien accueillis à de
mourgues et fabrice dujardin
rien à signaler pour l'instant nous
sommes dans le centre ville
ici une commerçante s'est récemment fait
agressé à coups de barres de fer une de
plus mohamed sillonnent le quartier pour
prévenir tout acte de délinquance
ici la peur se vit au quotidien tout de
suite évident aux yeux qui s'en vient
défaut aux mains des cracheurs ou alors
on
12h20 on attend à cette heure-là sorties
seront envoyés à la police mise grâce
aux médiateurs la délinquance
commencerait à chuter mais mohamed n'est
pas policier
il est emplois jeunes jamais il ne
remplacera les forces de l'ordre si
marion de cette évaluation physique
physique avec des armes
on n'a pas directement les services
compétents et on hurle simplement
quartier des trois-ponts un des plus
sensibles
les médiateurs semble bien seul la
police serait quasi absente trop peu
nombreuses il manquerait 110 postes sur
la ville
francine vient d'être victime d'une
tentative de cambriolage
elle attend les renforts avec impatience
erevan invitera soit plus c'est trop
peur de sortir
enfermé à la maison enfin pour faire une
course au salon c'est fini pourquoi
intéressé depuis des années le maire
aussi réclament plus de policiers on
aménage même de nouveaux commissariats
tout d'abord on ne peut pas réussir une
politique de prévention de la
délinquance si l'on n'oublie que la
police est un service public essentiel
dont la présence doit être renforcée
dans nos quartiers le problème c'est que
ces premiers création d'emplois les
annonces d'aujourd'hui on les verra sur
le terrain que dans deux ans
ce qu il ya une gymnastique budgétaire
ce qui fait que ben il faut regretter il
faut former et on retrouvera des
premiers fonctionnaires citoyens en
passant de 3000 on les retrouvera sur le
terrain en 2004 mais combien seront ils
accepté de venir un roubaix ironie du
sort c'est ici que l'on trouve l'une des
écoles de police les plus réputés mais
une fois former les jeunes recrues
choisit souvent de partir ailleurs
loin très loin des quartiers sensibles à
aulnay sous bois en seine saint denis
deux jeunes qui étaient impliqués dans
les violences urbaines du 14 juillet ont
été condamnés aujourd'hui à quatre et
deux mois de prison ferme par le
tribunal de bobigny à versailles c'est
tribunal administratif qui a suspendu
l'arrêté municipal détente qui
instaurait un couvre-feu général sur
toute la commune pour les mineurs de
moins de 13 ans et puis dans l'ain les
gendarmes recherchent une jeune fille de
16 ans disparue dans un bal du 14
juillet en réplique à la déferlante de
jacques chirac sur la sécurité lionel
jospin a donc fait connaître aujourd'hui
les budgets de chaque ministère pour
l'an prochain
l'intérieur et la justice sont parmi les
mieux lotis dans ce que l'on appelle un
budget de campagne
amaury guibert et jérôme soûlard
le budget 2002 prend des allures de
contre attaque après les déclarations de
jacques chirac samedi dernier première
priorité affichée la sécurité un sujet
sur lequel le président de la république
avait concentré son offensive
le budget du ministère de l'intérieur
est en hausse de 4,3 pour cent
de quoi recruter 3000 nouveaux policiers
bien mais peut mieux faire répondre les
syndicats ça va dans le bon sens nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est que nos concitoyens
demandent de plus en plus de sécurité
ce qu'on aurait souhaité s et qui a un
plan pluriannuel le 6 milliards
supplémentaires à hauteur de 2 milliards
par an à compter de janvier 2002 et
concret 20000 emplois sur quatre ans
autre priorité la justice dont les
crédits augmentent de 5 et demi pour
cent à la clé deux mille sept cents
nouveaux postes mais les magistrats ne
sont pas sûr d'en être les bénéficiaires
si l'augmentation est affecté uniquement
à l'administration pénitentiaire ou à
d'autres services
nos concitoyens nous ne verrons pas le
la réalité de l'augmentation
le troisième axe du prochain budget
c'est l'éducation nationale c'est là que
les dépenses sont les plus importantes
elles augmentent de 4% 7000 emplois
seront créés l'environnement lui
rattrape son retard
ce ministère souvent délaissée voit ses
crédits augmenter de 7% environnement
justice police ou l'éducation
les thèmes de ce budget ont un parfum
électoral l'armée elle devrait créer une
nouvelle pomme de discorde
jacques chirac avait plaidé pour une
hausse sensible du budget de la défense
le gouvernement lui a décidé qu'elle
sera inférieure à la moyenne
et pour que rien ne manque dans ce
budget 2002 le ministère de la culture
obtiendra 1 % des crédits un seuil
symbolique qui n'avait jamais été
atteint
les commentaires de l'opposition sur ces
lettres plafonds qui sont les dépenses
de l'état pour démocratie libérale la
copie est médiocre et pour le rpr et les
laxistes et ne tient pas compte du
ralentissement de la croissance le
conseil des ministres de demain lui
risque d'être glacial après les
amabilités échangées ces derniers jours
hier soir encore jean glavany parler
d'outrance d'exagération de manipulation
de mensonges à propos du chef de l'état
de tels propos de la part d'un ministre
de la république montre bien que la
cohabitation a changé de nature
laurent hakim et alix bouilhaguet on
pourrait presque en faire une histoire
sans paroles quand on a l'impression que
tout a été dit par chacun des deux camps
là le président critique rien sur les
retraites pas assez pour la sécurité
on peut contre le chômage là le
gouvernement répond mauvaise foi deal
une confusion des genres ajoute l'autre
méthodes d'un autre âge dit encore une
collègue
depuis chacun des deux camps vac de
nouveau à ses occupations le premier
ministre reçoit le chanteur pop de
youtou le président de la république lui
distribuer des médailles et s'autorise
même une envolées mystiques les gardiens
m'ont entraînée dans le sanctuaire où
les populaires mais gauche attendaient
silencieux le bouddha sourire du côté
des autres candidats à la présidentielle
ou pour les moins loquace dans leur
entourage l'attitude à adopter est un
peu celle de ce proverbe arabe
assieds-toi sur le bord du fleuve et tu
verras passé le corps de ton ennemi bon
il y a un grand tohu bohu mais qui
dissimule un accord sur l'essentiel on
sait ce qu'on a à en attendre de ces
deux là ils vont effectivement s'envoyer
des choses désagréables à la figure
c'est pas très passionnant nous
semble-t-il c'est un petit peu fête
foraine demain l'avant dernier conseil
des ministres avant la plage risque
d'être tendu mais les miracles de la
cohabitation et du protocole devrait
permettre de sauver les apparences mais
pendant ce temps là les juges poursuivre
leur enquête sur les voyages de jacques
chirac payé en liquide avec l'audition
de jean claude lhaumond l'ancien
chauffeur du maire de paris
il a été entendu pendant trois heures
par la police c'est lui qui à de
nombreuses reprises et auraient alors
cédé en bloquant aux voyagistes de
jacques chirac il a toujours dit jusqu'à
présent qu'il ne savait pas si elle
contenait de l'argent
jacques chirac lui a signé le décret de
grâce présidentielle du 14 juillet re
décret dont sont notamment exclus les
auteurs de crimes et délits sur les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans les auteurs
d'actes de terrorisme et de trafic de
stupéfiants
les médicaments contre le rhume
désormais sur ordonnance et une décision
de l'agencé française de sécurité
sanitaire une vingtaine de médicaments
très grand public sont donc concernés
thomas dandois et laurence de chair ces
médicaments au tir une plus question de
les prendre au hasard dès la fin du mois
il faudra une ordonnance l' agence
française de sécurité sanitaires
estiment qu'ils peuvent en de rares
occasions provoquer des hémorragies
cérébrales
en tout vingt produits sont concernés
des produits largement utilisés par le
grand public
alors les professionnels craignent de
voir leur clientèle déboussolés tous les
jours on
trois quatre boîtes par jour vous
pouvoir faire des vernal c'est vraiment
un bon produit pour les clients et ils
vont pas comprendre pourquoi au sein 0-1
les médecins eux comprennent qu'il
s'agit là d'une décision de bon sens
laissé à la disposition des patients en
délivrance totalement libre des
médicaments qui vont les rendre malades
n'est par exemple aux états unis ces
produits ont été retirés du marché
depuis presque un an
une étude a démontré qu'il contenait de
la fenps il prend pas nos la mine une
molécule jugée dangereuse pour la santé
publique
ce qu'on sait c'est qu en europe et
enfouir y compris la france ya à peu
près une dizaine de cas rapportés au vu
des dizaines de millions de voix
consommées chaque année en cas de rhume
il faudra désormais choisir d'autres
produits en vente libre ou bien passer
par la case médecin
mais même avec une ordonnance la plupart
de ces médicaments ne sont pas
remboursables
rien n'est fait pour un om air liberté
le tribunal de créteil pourrait même
reporté sa décision sur l'avenir de la
compagnie prévue jeudi
il doit choisir vous savez entre les
projets des différents repreneurs et
puis sachez qu alcatel va supprimer plus
d'un quart de ses effectifs outre-manche
environ 300 personnes alors que philips
annonce lui un nouveau plan de 3,4 4000
suppressions d'emplois à l'étranger la
ville de gênes en italie s'apprête à
accueillir le sommet du g8 et son lot de
militants anti mondialisation pour
l'occasion des autorités italiennes ont
rétabli le contrôle aux frontières pour
filtrer ce qu'elles jugent indésirable
c'est ainsi que 5 à 600 policiers et
gendarmes français vont se déployer
entre menton et vintimille josé bové
d'ailleurs a été retenu quelques heures
au poste frontière de fréjus du côté
italien
et puis à calais la police française
refoulera également les militants anti
mondialisation arrivant de grande
bretagne
la ville de gênes elle s'est transformée
en camp retranché avec un espace quand
même pour les manifestants et puis un
navire flambant neuf pour les chefs
d'état un jeune auxiliaire des
carabiniers a été blessé par un attentat
à la lettre piégée et un colis suspect a
également été désamorcée reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux
pascal golomer et gilles jacquier
ce soir il peut encore franchir la
grille sans aucun contrôle mais demain à
partir de 7 heures il faudra montrer son
laissez-passer pour pénétrer dans le
centre historique de gère une dizaine
d'issue seulement seront ouvertes ce
quartier de quatre kilomètres carrés
prendra alors l'apparence d'un camp
retranché
baptisées zones rouges par la police
l'idée n'était évidemment pas du goût de
tous les habitants ma première était
tout près d'écrire moi j'habite heures
dans l'autre arrêt à l'offre papier fait
les jambes
voilà je peux pas parfait vous l'aurez
pas toujours je peux trouver mon père
mandat beaucoup de commerçants installés
dans le périmètre ont d'ailleurs décidé
de fermer boutique durant la semaine
faute de clients mais aussi par peur des
manifestations
pourtant l'objectif de la police c'est
évidemment d'empêcher toute intrusion
dans la zone qui englobe le palais ducal
là où se réuniront les huit chefs d'état
quinze mille policiers et militaires
sont mobilisés pour l'occasion et les
contrôles d'identité se multiplient déjà
auprès des visiteurs jugés suspects
la police préfère voir les manifestants
ici le moins du centre ville en bord de
mer au quartier général du forum social
un contre-sommet en quelque sorte qui
réunit des centaines d'associations
quelques milliers de personnes sont déjà
arrivées
les débats ont commencé à propos de la
mondialisation des échanges ou de la
lutte contre la pauvreté
d'autres préfèrent s'initier à la
performance théâtrale de rue avec pour
thème la lutte non violente
les autorités italiennes ont donc choisi
de tenir les manifestants à l'écart du
port de gênes et de la ville là où
résideront les délégations officielles
cela sera-t-il suffisant pour éviter les
violences les manifestantes en tout cas
appelé à partir à l'assaut de la zone
protégée
tout au long de la journée de vendredi
en israël après l'attentât suicide qui a
fait trois morts hier les représailles
se multiplient bombardements israéliens
sur des positions palestiniennes en
cisjordanie raid d'hélicoptères sur
bethléem et tirs de mortier palestiniens
près de jérusalem
le cessez le feu du 13 juin paraît bien
loin sur place charles enderlin et
joseph handal quatre hommes sont morts
ici
un hélicoptère de combat israélien a
tiré des roquettes sur ce qui était une
maison
le chef du ramasse pour la région de
bethléem et trois de ses adjoints ont
été tués officiellement cette attaque
entre dans le cadre de la politique
d'auto défense active d'israël
les militants du ramasse promettre de
venger ces morts et cela en dépit des
avertissements de leur a lancé
l'autorité palestinienne qui leur
interdit toute attente à toute attaque à
l'intérieur du territoire et cède la
région va donc connaître un nouveau
cycle de violences notamment à hébron où
après une semaine de dur combat
la ville a vécu une journée de calme
relatif dans les quartiers sous le
contrôle de l'autorité palestinienne
la population en a profité pour
s'approvisionner
les israéliens tirent au hasard sur les
maisons quand ça commence je cache les
enfants c'est vraiment injuste de devoir
subir de tels tirs
le secteur occupé par l'armée
israélienne est sous couvre feu depuis
six jours enfermés dans les maisons
quarante mille palestiniens ne peuvent
qu'attendre et regarder la télévision
mais pas les principales chaînes locales
comme deux de ses consoeurs al noura ce
la station de wael el chori a été
bombardé il ya trois jours les tirs sont
venus de cette position israélienne
ils se sont poursuivis toute la nuit
nous diffusions en direct les échanges
de tirs et aussi comment les colons
brûler les médecins
ce soir la population de hébron
s'apprête à passer une nouvelle nuit
dans la peur
un sentiment partagé par les colons
juifs qui habitent le secteur ici tel
remède à en plein centre de la ville en
moins d'une semaine les combats les
embuscades ont fait deux morts trois
blessés israéliens un morts une centaine
de blessés palestiniens
mais l'insécurité régnait également au
sud de jérusalem où pour la première
fois les palestiniens ont tiré
aujourd'hui un obus de mortier sur dix
lots le quartier genou l'armée
israélienne a riposté
en irlande du nord belfast a connu une
nouvelle nuit de violences entre
catholiques et protestants plusieurs
policiers qui tentaient de s'interposer
ont été blessés l'armée a été appelée en
renfort là aussi les accords de paix du
vendredi saint paraissent dans l'impasse
et puis un nouveau massacre en algérie
12 personnes assassinées la nuit
dernière près de médéa à 80 km au sud
d'alger reste y de gilles rabin avec sur
place moments d'oubli
c'est le quatrième massacres de
villageois sans défense en moins d'une
seconde
4 massacre tous perpétrés de nuit avec
la même sauvagerie qui tuent sans
distinction hommes femmes et enfants
aient le même mystère sur l'identité des
véritables aux auteurs
quand elle a entendu des coups de feu ma
tante est monté sur sa terrasse pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passait
son fils est allé voir et il a trouvé
son frère assassiné explique ce rescapé
du village de berrouaghia un petit
village à 80 km au sud d'alger qui sont
les assaillants de source officielle des
islamistes intégristes
d'après les témoins pourtant certains
portaient des uniformes
au total douze personnes ont été
assassinées dans la nuit la plus jeune
des victimes venaient d'avoir six ans un
petit garçon qui a été tué dans cette
baraque dans son lit à l'âge il est le
seul survivant d'une famille de six
personnes
les villageois sont armés at il confié
mais un seul d'entre eux a riposté le
concorde a donc volé à nouveau en
conditions réelles au dessus de l'aide
de l'atlantique à vitesse supersonique
un premier vol d'essai confié à british
airways en vue d'une nouvelle
qualification de l'appareil
après la catastrophe de gonesse qui
avait fait 113 morts l'an dernier
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
patrick fandio et guillaume faudra
ils n'ont pas hésité pirater la radio de
la tour de contrôle pour ne rien manquer
pour tout entendre pouvoir quand leur
avion favori le concorde s'envolera sous
leurs yeux dans quelques minutes déjà vu
décoller mais pas ma fille
c'est un grand jour alors un grand jour
le jour j pour le concorde britannique
dont c'est le premier vol depuis le
crash d'il ya un an
le commandant ben and eastern a pas
l'air inquiet aux commandes d'un
appareil sensiblement modifié le groupe
michelin lui résistant mais surtout
réservoir renforcer protéger ces
dernières semaines par une fine couche
de kevlar pour amortir les chocs et
limiter les éventuelles fuites de
carburant quatre mois de retard pour
cette opération qui s'est avérée
complexe et fort coûteuse
ce sont près de 200 millions de francs
qui ont été dépensés par british airways
pour procéder à toutes les modifications
c'est dire combien ce vol est capitale
pour la reprise éventuelle de
l'exploitation commerciale du
supersonique
mais avant cette reprise envisagée pour
septembre
il faudra d'abord que le supersonique
2006 plusieurs vols tests comme celui ci
confirme dans les airs les calculs des
ingénieurs il ya une heure qu'il s'est
posé sur la base militaire de brighton
tout semble s'être déroulé dans les
conditions normales c'était un vol
fantastique dit le commandant bannister
de l'avion s'est très bien comportée
j'aimerais remercier tous les ingénieurs
qui ont travaillé des deux côtés de la
manche
c'est au groupe d'experts
franco-britannique qui se réunit la
semaine prochaine à londres de donner
maintenant ou non le feu vert pour la
reprise des vols les victimes françaises
du nuage de tchernobyl se dit satisfaite
après l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire par le parquet de paris une
première en europe
sur les cinquante et une personnes qui
se disent victimes de tchernobyl en
france seules les plaintes de 25 d'entre
elles ont été retenues par le parquet
florent muller et muriel la saga ça
paraissait si loin de tchernobyl en 1986
les autorités françaises avaient rassuré
tout le monde
le nuage radioactif s'arrêtera gentiment
ou postes frontières de l'urss
je ne pense pas que ça puisse aller à
une échelle
supérieur à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres aux alentours de la centrale
si loin et si proche à la fois en 1996
jean claude fourès doit quitter son
emploi il est atteint d'un cancer de la
thyroïde on sait désormais que le nuage
a bel et bien traversé la france et pas
de doute selon lui il est victime de la
catastrophe pour la teinte pour moi
personnellement c'est que notre nom la
vie soit reconnue intelligente parce
qu'au point de vue professionnel
nous n'existons que la société en mars
dernier il porte plainte aux côtés de 50
autres malades
reprochant aux autorités de l'époque
leur immobilisme face à la catastrophe
pour la première fois en europe le
parquet de paris a ouvert une
information judiciaire
il appartient au juge d'aller d'abord
chercher les éléments d'information là
où ils se trouvent dans les différents
ministères dans les différentes
administrations concernées pour
déterminer ce que les autorités savaient
à l'époque et ce sur quoi elles ont pris
leur décision
l'enquêté a été confiée au juge
marie-odile bertella-geffroy celle là
même qui avait conduit l'instruction sur
le sang contaminé
mais à ce jour aucune étude scientifique
n'a prouvé l'existence d'un lien entre
le passage du nuage radioactif et
l'apparition des cas de cancers de la
thyroïde
malgré le mauvais temps les touristes
trouvent toujours à s'occuper dans le
bassin d'arcachon visite des parcs à
huîtres avec caroline femmes et patrick
voix
la tradition ostréicole du bassin
d'arcachon un univers qui se découvre
quand les eaux se retirent les hommes
vivent ici au rythme des marées d'où les
jours jean jacques chanteur beck navigue
vers ses parcs à huîtres mais cette fois
il n'est pas si fréquent de voir
certains ostréiculteurs se contente
d'une visite guidée du 8 mai ses
passagers à contribution un tourisme
instructif on peut expliquer comment sa
vie comment comme un grand disent
comment elles naissent nos difficultés
nos problèmes et puis nos plaisirs et
nos joie parce qu'on venait là quand
même suffisamment heureusement et puis
c'est toujours intéressant
par le biais de la route de lutte de
pouvoir amener les gens à découvrir le
bassin à découvrir les huîtres à
découvrir la qualité de vie quelques
maladresses bien sûr mais qu'importe
participer si mesuré l'ampleur du
travail ont freiné par des tubes ce
milieu et c'est vrai c'est une
découverte la pression d'installation en
installation d d d d d poche
l'installation de triage de triage ddd
18 de nettoyage qui se passe dans caen
rennes et toulouse
donc c'est un ensemble
un ensemble indissociable de ce lieu
unique transformé par l'essor de
l'ostréiculture au xixème siècle un lieu
dont le patrimoine est préservé une
carte postale
on a vraiment l'impression d'être au
bout du monde et ce n'est pas forcément
une impression d'ailleurs n'est
peut-être vraiment vous demandez
pourquoi pas
ben ali s'était peut-être trompé le
centre du monde c'est pas la gare de
perpignan 7 la scène d'arcachon
m
de quoi séduire les touristes et
pourquoi pas susciter des vocations pour
si mauvais que ça le feuilleton des rave
parties continuent après l'aveyron et la
moselle le week-end dernier cette fois
c'est une rave géante qui est redouté en
marge du festival des vieilles charrues
dans le finistère on annonce 50 mille
personnes et les autorités s'inquiètent
un peu béatrice blondeau et alexandre de
laval christian troadec est un homme
inquiet
l'année dernière le maire de carhaix a
vu défiler en marge du festival annuel
des vieilles charrues 32000 rêveur dans
ce champ résultats de la fête improvisée
les dégâts ont été chiffré à 400 mille
francs et il aura fallu une semaine pour
tout remettre en état
alors à trois jours du festival la
prudence est de rigueur
on a alerté les services préfectoraux le
préfet du finistère mais aussi ceux du
morbihan et des côtes-d'armor qu'on est
à la limite des trois départements et
donc on espère aujourd'hui que la
sécurité des biens et des personnes
elle sera respectée du côté des
organisateurs du festival ont craint
cette année les débordements pour ce cru
les vieilles charrues affiche en effet
complet dans ces conditions difficile
d'empêcher les 170 mille personnes
attendues ce week end de participer à
des free parties effectivement je crois
qu'on peut craindre les choses parce que
il n'ya pas de sécurité mises en place
et sur l'ennemi pour les biens ni pour
les personnes il n'y a non plus aucune
hygiène du côté des habitants de cette
petite ville de 8000 âmes
les avis sont en tout cas partagé
j'ai fait dans ma jeunesse aussi
permanent mes marques
si tout ce passe bien c'est merveilleux
mais malheureusement il ne verra pas les
pillards ont valu ce qu'on l'écouté on a
un peu peur d'être vous déranger mais on
va de 6 pour l'heure on ne connaît ni le
lieu ni même le jour exact de la rave
party une rêve qui pourrait rassembler
jusqu'à 50 personnes
et c'est peut-être le mauvais temps qui
va mettre tout le monde d'accord
françois prix va vous lisez tout à
l'heure un peu plus bas à la rochelle ou
francofolies il a fallu annuler le grand
concert de ce soir pour cause de tempête
mais festival continue éric perrin et
christophe vignal ont rencontré hier
quand il faisait beau pascal parisot
il a 37 ans il son premier album sorti
il ya seulement deux mois fait un
malheur mambo est bon bout chanson bric
à brac à 37 ans l'âge où d'autres ont
déjà fini leur carrière pascal parisot
sort son premier album avec ses textes
décalés savoie la gainsbourg période
javanaise parisot est comme un ovni dans
le ciel de la chanson française
il prétend que à l'accord
alors je suis allé faire un somme je
n'ai vu que des shows par des gens trop
tard qu'il est toujours mal quelque part
je tue
coc
avant ce disque pascal et frédéric sa
compagne ont galéré durant dix ans en
jouant de la bossa nova dans les piano
bars on pourrait donc croire que c'est
pour cette raison que l'album s'intitule
rumba et bien pas du roomba ça tellement
mon chien quand j'étais petit sur scène
on retrouve cet esprit celui d'un disque
entièrement enregistré à la maison avec
il faut le dire du matériel top of the
top high tech dernier cri
disons qu'elle était donc je veux dire
que moi je gère son que personne d'autre
à salluit quoi la preuve
mais cette musique légère est au service
de textes finement écrit dans un style
découvert dans cette chanson d'amour
celle qui a tout déclenché surtout quand
tu loin de moi je me taire je l'avais
fait en cinq minutes pour faire rire
ma compagne déjà d'azur et puis les amis
je t'aime quand tu as une est
pas question de vous un job évidemment
ça les a fait rire et ils m'ont dit mais
ça mais c'est vachement bien
moi je suis sam et lance pas possible on
peut pas chanter ça c'est pas possible
eh bien si
tusi nahon peu près tout près soit en
donnant jusqu'au dernier dollar
en des temps le coup sans aucun décor
enfin de boris vian et de nino ferrer
une image parisot a ce don de toujours
faire sourire et ça c'est beau ça
pour moi
voilà et demain la rochelle ce sera
henri salvador qui fête ses 84 avant de
refermer ce journal je vous rappelle les
principaux titres météo france appelle
les habitants et les touristes de toute
la façade ouest de la france à la plus
grande prudence on annonce des vents
violents inhabituelles en cette saison
et puis le coup d'éclat de lance
armstrong l'américain impose son rythme
au tour de france il remporte l'étape à
l'alpe d'huez s'impose devant jan
ullrich
mais c'est françois simon comme tribus
qui prend le maillot jaune
voilà tout de suite la météo justement
avec isabelle martinez vers 00h10 le
dernier journal ce sera alexandre kara
demain dans les 4 vérités l'invité sera
ségolène royal à 13h vos forêts laurence
ostolaza et quant à moi j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver ici
nous allons tourner de 20h bonne soirée
sur france 2
moi